адже як він frenzy asbis поки ви наклав
троянд впав холодної війни спитаю тут
умовляю трансатлантичних братію то
про надбання за срср спочатку
дев'яностих почалося запитують україни
до поліпшення складу буру так цієї ж
пісня теракті 11 валися не пішов
конференція стала найважливішою
європейським форумом спробувати глобальну
би спайк та й самий тут за іронію
9 років тому президент Росії висловив
свою відому мюнхенську мову м'який
заявивши що дозволить шато на то1
сильно корвата святим форма vape означало
початок нового протесту не і за ходом
столаце відразу мило значить і пиздих і
заводом після анексії крима чи агресії
на донбасі
касла до ангела меркель стейдж трибуна за
кликала путіна по вожатий міжнародне
право
а Петра Порошенка просто його зброю її і
показав паспорт та російських ризикових
за трьом інших на донбасі учасники тиснемо
фінської конференції з важливих експертів
tab або таки на жаль рішення глобальних
конфліктів традиційно в'януть порвав на
формальним злодіїм не
результати цих взводів можете
реалізувати і себе публіці полетіти